Burns Supper originated when Robert Burns' friends got together after he died...
...as a memorial to his enduring life and legacy,...
...but now it's morphed into a countrywide celebration.
Everyone around Scotland, around the world...
...gets together to celebrate Robert Burns.
They celebrate in their houses.
They celebrate in hotels.
They drink.
They eat traditional Scottish food.
They listen to Scottish music,...
...and they, most importantly, read and appreciate Robbie Burns' poetry.
Robbie Burns was voted the Greatest Scot of all time by STV in 2009,...
...a pretty impressive accomplishment for anyone because over time,...
...there have been a lot of pretty amazing people who came out of Scotland,...
...and Robert Burns, no. 1!
He died at just 37,...
...but before he died, he wrote 550 poems and songs.
He's known as "The Bard,"...
...one of the greatest poets ever to come from Scotland.
What he is also known for is being political.
He inspired the likes of Martin Luther King, Winston Churchill,...
...Abraham Lincoln; I mean, this is a pretty impressive guy.
Burns Night is on the 25th of January every year.
It's to mark his birthday.
The traditional Burns celebration is the Burns Supper.
This typically involves people wearing a lot of tartan,...
...drinking a lot of whiskey, eating a lot of haggis...
...and listening to a lot of great poetry.
The pinnacle of Burns Supper is always the haggis.
For the uninitiated, haggis is a savory pudding...
...containing  sheep's heart, liver, lungs,...
...which is minced with onion, oatmeal, suet,...
...stock and a veritable plethora of other spices.
It's traditionally sheathed in an animal's stomach.
It might not sound delicious, but it's actually really nice.